in theoretical physics to get this kind
of audience you have to like win the
nobel prize or something but uh of
course i've been working on ml recently
and uh
it's been much more exciting there's a
huge amount of interest so uh to some
extent part of what i'll be talking
about maybe an implicit theme will be
sort of why there's so much excitement
and why you might expect that excitement
to to continue
um so
an outline of my talk is that i'll first
start by
um discussing motivations for language
modeling i'm sure you're all very well
motivated because this is this is an nlp
class
and also talk about sort of orders of
magnitude of data and compute that go
into contemporary language modeling
and that will kind of set the stage for
talking about um scaling laws for neural
language modeling and
a further realization that these scaling
laws seem to be quite universal for
generative models and maybe for sort of
machine learning uh more generally and
then uh finally after discussing that
i'll talk about what happens when we
actually do scale up language models
i'll talk about the gbt3 model and if
there's time i'll talk about some
lessons from all of these ideas for
research which i imagine many of you are
excited to
be involved with soon
so i'll start by talking about uh
why we do language modeling and fermi
estimates for language modeling by fermi
estimates i mean questions like
estimating is it uh are there are there
uh
a million or a hundred thousand or ten
thousand piano tuners in chicago for me
famously asked this kind of question and
there are a lot of estimates like this
that we can kind of do in the back of
the envelope way to really get a sense
for uh for what's going on
so
um but but before going into that um why
should you study language this is sort
of my motivation you might have all
sorts of other motivations language is
obviously a very fascinating uh
intellectual creation by by our species
um but i think another reason why it's
particularly exciting for ai is that
language is in some sense our species
best attempt to encode everything about
the world in as efficient and compressed
way as possible and that means that uh
that it's very yielding to uh to to an
ai there isn't a lot of noise um there's
a lot of signal um there's of course a
huge quantity of writing freely
available on the internet and there are
also a huge number of of books for
example uh i think very roughly speaking
in this sort of fermi estimate level
there's something like 10 million books
in the library of congress um and
very very roughly that might mean
there's something like a trillion words
out there in books and then there's
actually much more language information
out on the internet um and so there's
therefore a lot of data
for for ai models to learn from
and then a third reason at least for uh
to some extent for me and maybe for many
of you is that if you're actually able
to get an ai that uh that kind of knows
quote-unquote understands language then
you can communicate with it in a kind of
natural way you can ask it about
anything and you can get a lot of
intuition for from the responses and
behaviors and all sorts of different
kinds of evaluations you can perform on
such a model um if you compare it to
sort of uh ancient history of ai like
like excitement about classifying images
from i don't know
alex net 10 years ago in sort of uh the
distant past and from say alphago again
in the distant past five years ago um
there's a lot more intuition you can get
and then you can you can use that to
sort of understand what these models
know and don't know and can do um and
you can also think about this in terms
of how to uh
make these models aligned with what
humans prefer there's a lot of work on
trying to understand
language model bias racism other such
issues and there's really a lot that you
can kind of explore and dig into
so um i imagine this is all very basic
for everyone here but just just so we're
on the same page um if you're doing kind
of contemporary neural network-based
machine learning
the ingredients that you need to get
started are really surprisingly simple
you need some kind of model um to
parameterize a function you need a data
set
um you need some computers with plenty
of computation you need a loss function
and you need some choice of optimizer
and basically for for pretty much
everything in this talk i'll be thinking
about
language modeling is a task where the
loss function is simply to predict the
next word in
uh some sentence or paragraph or or book
um and so that's how basically all of
the models that i'll be i'll be talking
about are trained they have a loss
function which incentivizes them to
correct to predict the correct
probability distribution for for the
next word
um but what about these other
ingredients like uh like the models that
we use the data sets that we use and
how much computation do we use what what
are those sort of uh order of magnitude
figures
um so
one one way to think about this is sort
of how much language do we consume
as as a person for for comparison so you
could imagine that if you're a very
voracious reader
maybe you'd read a long book every day
and you'd spend your life doing that
maybe you'd live for 70 years if you did
that you'd end up reading something like
two billion words over your lifetime
um for a comparison uh a canonical large
language model gpg3 was trained for on
the order of uh 200 billion words so
that's about a hundred times more
uh language data than than maybe you'd
see in your lifetime if you kind of
tried really hard to attend to to
written text
there are other data sets of course that
are much much bigger than uh than gpt
3's trading set
there's common crawl which is a sort of
snapshot of the internet that anyone can
go out and
download if you like this has very
roughly on the order of 10 to the 15
words
i said earlier that the library of
congress has something like uh maybe 10
million books each book is maybe 100 000
words
so uh the library of congress in total
maybe has something like a trillion
words
um
and as another sort of smaller
data set example
english wikipedia is very roughly of
order three billion words so maybe if
you spent your whole life reading
wikipedia you could just barely do it
if that was your mission
um so what about the
actual neural networks that i'll be
talking about that we currently seem to
be using uh fairly effectively to model
language
so i'll be talking about transformer
language models um so-called decoder
only transformer language models uh of
which gpg3 is an example
and just to sort of count things um
these models have uh with kind of their
the standard way that they're set up a
number of parameters which is something
like 12 times the number of layers in
the network so gpd3 has 96 layers you
can make
deeper or shallower such networks
times the sort of activation dimension
squared so uh d model this this d
d model parameter is just the dimension
of the vector space that each token
occupies
or or word if you were to use two words
as tokens um when you run this model on
on language data um and so
uh this gives you some sense for for for
where parameter comes come from i think
d model for gpd 3 is of order 10 000 and
and layer is 96 and that's how you get
roughly 200 uh billion parameters in
that model and other models scale
similarly um now how much computation do
you actually do when you train this kind
of model
well it turns out that uh
different neural network architectures
have different properties with respect
to this question but transformers are
actually quite simple
in that in a forward pass of of a
transformer every parameter
on every token performs roughly one add
and one multiply
and then about twice this in the
backward pass and so that gives us a
very simple formula that the number of
floating point operations that a model
like this performs during training
is
six which is two times one plus two
um times the number of parameters in the
model times the number of tokens that's
what d is sort of the size of the data
set and tokens that you that you process
and one other point that sort of i'll
make while uh kind of
going over these these these
estimates is that you might wonder
whether or not there's a lot of
computation
involved in processing long sequences
um there's sort of a famous there's a
famous point that dense attention in
transformer models um is n squared with
respect to context length and that's
absolutely true
however
if you actually work out uh the sort of
coefficients the ratio of the amount of
computation you do in a forward pass or
during training
in the context direction versus in the
direction of sort of moving up the
layers of the model
is roughly and context over 12 times d
model
so um i i note this just because if you
think which uh i'll kind of suggest that
this is this is a likely direction for
for the world to be heading that models
might continue to get bigger
then
um d model for gpd three is already ten
thousand
so the denominator here is order a
hundred thousand and so actually even if
you have quite long context with the
sort of dumbest possible dense attention
the amount of compute you actually do
in the context direction is not not
always so large
um
what about so what about actually
numerical values for for this this
compute so the largest models that we
have so far if we're in kind of fermi
estimate mode we can round up and say
they have say order a trillion
parameters
um
if you have a model with a trillion
parameters
um
then uh then what kind of hardware are
you gonna run it on well you might run
it on an a100 gpu at least this year and
a 100 gpus perform about three times 10
to the 14
floating point operations per second
or 2 times 10 to the 19 floating point
operations per day
this means that it's sort of convenient
to
sometimes use units of petaflop days
which is 10 to the 15 floating point
operations per second times a day
um and that means that's that's about
three a 100 days
and that's about 8.6 times 10 to the 19
or order 10 to the 20 uh floating point
operations um in a day
so
how does how does sort of the compute
available on hardware compared to the
compute that we do when we train these
gigantic models well if we have a model
with a trillion parameters and we train
it for
300 billion tokens then we get 6
times 10 to the 12 times 3 times 10 to
the 11 and so we get on the order of uh
10 to the 24 floating point
operations to train a trillion parameter
model for uh uh on one of these large
data sets so these these numbers
involved i mean i think the thing that i
find most amazing about this is that i
still remember
taking chemistry in high school and in
chemistry you learn that sort of a
macroscopic amount of stuff
is sort of an avogadro's number of atoms
which is like 6 times 10 to the 23. so
somehow we're actually able to build
computers that do that that working
together do more than an avogadro's
number of computations to to train these
neural models
so anyway i i find these numbers kind of
mind-boggling and and also useful to
sort of have in the back of your head to
understand what's what's going on
so um with that uh prelude unless there
are any questions um i'll start talking
about scaling laws for these kinds of
language models
so
um what i'll basically be arguing is
that there are very surprisingly precise
empirical scaling laws
for the performance
of machine learning systems machine
learning models as a function of
kind of gross macroscopic inputs like
how many parameters does the model have
how big is the data set and how much
compute is used for training
um
and
i'll also make the point that if you're
sort of
in an airplane at 30 000 feet looking
down on what's going on in the field a
lot of the other details in these
systems don't matter all that much or at
least they don't matter as much as you
might have expected that they would
very often they just change some kind of
constant pre-factor in in these these
kinds of
scaling laws which give you kind of the
big picture of what's changing as you
really increase uh these these inputs
and
one way of sort of
uh turning this into sort of a theme
what do you learn from it how do you
summarize it is that getting these
models to perform better is to a large
extent about kind of avoiding
blo bottlenecks it's avoiding being
blocked by something and there are a lot
of things that that can can block
improvements in performance
the most obvious one which uh which is
what scaling laws are studying is you
could not have enough data you could not
have a large enough model you cannot
have enough computation to train that
model
and then there are also a lot of other
literal bottlenecks that you can think
of think about many of which involve
sort of bad information propagation
through the network so i guess like one
way that i would summarize a lot of the
most highly cited papers in machine
learning in the last 10 years papers
like about things like like resnets and
uh layer norm batch norm things like
that is that they're sort of alleviating
bottlenecks where information wasn't
propagating nicely through through your
network and
the the sort of simplest possible
picture to sort of illustrate this which
perhaps is a cartoon of what's going on
something that i'll talk about later on
with lstms is that if you take a matrix
i mean neural networks are really just
fancy systems that do a lot of matrix
multiplication if you take a matrix and
you you multiply it a large number of
times
then
very roughly speaking what you end up
with is
a projection onto its largest uh
eigenspace and so
very roughly speaking if you have a deep
network and you sort of don't set it up
correctly it's very easy to be in a
situation where uh uh
you lose signal or lose information and
you get like a literal literal bottle um
but anyway that's that's sort of the the
philosophy that uh at least at zeroth
order might you might sort of uh reach
from
thinking about some of these results
so
uh this slide is really about the the
kind of core results for scaling laws
for language models and so i'll i'll
explain it in some detail
so
i'm actually going to start with the
plot on the far right which is about
scaling laws with respect to the number
of parameters in a neural network
and so
what we did to uh to generate this plot
was get a very large data set such that
we weren't worried about models
overfitting at all
and train all of our models for a very
long time so that they were essentially
at convergence
so in other words training time or
compute was not a constraint on
performance
and then plot the resulting test loss
of language models
trained to to predict the next word as a
function of parameter count um on a nice
log scale and so what you see is that
there's this this power law which is a
straight line on a log log plot
of the loss as a function of the
parameter count of these models
in the middle plot we do the same thing
but switch the role of
the amount of data that we have with
parameter count so we train a model
that's very large maybe one of the
largest models on the plot on on the
right
so that model size is not a constraint
on performance
on data sets of various sizes
and we apply early stopping so we
measure the test loss at the point where
the test loss is at its minimum during
otherwise pretty naive straightforward
trading
and we find uh again a very clear power
law for loss as a function of data set
size
and then the most complicated plot is
the one on the left
so
on the left we
[Music]
plot all of the learning curves
for
many different models
we provide these models with plenty of
data so they're not over fitting they're
in the under parametrized regime
but we
we train all these different model sizes
for a very very long time and we measure
on the x-axis not
the number of training steps or training
tokens but the amount of compute that
has been used so far during training
and as a consequence of one of the
formulas that i wrote on a couple of
slides ago that compute is six times
parameter count times the amount of
trading data
if you take the logarithm of both sides
the log of parameters times data is log
of parameters plus log of data so that
means is that learning curves for models
of different sizes are just shifted over
left and right by constant amounts with
the largest models
on the on the sort of the far right of
this curve and the smallest models on
the left
so we have the learning curves for all
of these models all put together and so
a question you can ask is sort of what
is the best loss you can get for any
given amount of training compute
where you're allowing yourself to choose
the model that that does best for that
amount of training compute and that's
what sort of the heavy black line
and the orange fit are are picking out i
mean formally you could call this the
something like the convex hull of all of
these curves um
and that again
somewhat somewhat surprisingly seems to
obey a a very nice power law fit over
many many orders of magnitude in
computation
and it's crucial for all of these
experiments that you're only limiting
performance with one
thing at a time on the far right you
have plenty of data and compute but
you're limiting the number of parameters
in the middle you're limiting the amount
of data but you have a big model on the
left you're uh you're looking at
training compute but you have all sorts
of different model sizes and again
plenty of data
so in other words in each of these cases
there's sort of one of these parameters
that's bottlenecking performance and
otherwise uh you have plenty of
resources there's a question
um i hope that's not true um so
there's a minus sign in the exponent i'm
not sure if you're looking at the uh the
lines or the the function
of the bottom axes on the right
let's see oh i see okay
yeah they're just just a long skill plot
um but yeah
please please ask any questions
great and then the the x-axis on this
compute plot is this petaflop a day
pedoplot day unit that's why it's it's
actually a small number
any other any other questions about
uh anything about this plot
cool so
um there's another thing that you can do
that's kind of interesting with the plot
on the left
which is you can ask for any given
quantity of compute that you have
available um someone kindly donates to
you some number of a100s to use for for
a few weeks and you want to use it to
train the best possible language model
you can and so you can ask based on this
plot on the left how should i allocate
the computation that was given to me
in terms of making a bigger model
or training longer
and it turns out there's sort of a
simplified cartoon for the answer that
that we found with with our language
data
which was that you mostly want to
allocate
most of your compute basically
two-thirds on a geometric scale to
making models bigger
and you can allocate about a third to
training for longer on more data
and so
this at least for us wasn't wasn't an
obvious
obvious conclusion it suggests that
a lot of the gains that you're going to
get um
if you want to get better performance
with a fixed amount of compute a fixed
budget is going to come from making
making your models bigger and it turns
out that in practice i won't go into it
in detail you can
to some extent just make your batch size
bigger during training and that means
that the total number of serial steps
that you train for doesn't have to
increase uh all that much you don't
necessarily have to train for fastly
longer um you you seemingly just need a
largely a bigger model
and that's something that you read off
from this this compute plot that i
showed you
um
sure um so
uh that's a general question so um the
way that the way that you get this graph
is you basically do an analysis where
you uh uh where you like you look at any
given point for compute and you look up
and you pick out the blue curve that's
closest to the black line and that gives
you a model size and an amount of
training and so you can do that um
uh in for for all of these different
points on the the x-axis and then for
any given point on this x-axis that
tells you a model size so you learn
model size as a function of your compute
budget um and then conversely you also
learn an amount of training which is
sort of a a data set size and so that's
the explanation for the uh
for this sort of million x model size
versus a thousand x in in data um i
i probably won't try to explain the
batch size question but it's basically
based on some empirical analysis where
you ask um how big can you make your
batch size
how far can you push data parallelism um
without seeing diminishing returns and
that's that's sort of the rough answer
from from that question
they're all trained from scratch so this
is always uh almost everything that i'll
talk about in this talk is training from
scratch
any other questions
okay
and then another point that uh i mean i
don't want to overemphasize but like i
said from a sort of very zeroth order
naive perspective is that for some of
these results architecture isn't the
most crucial thing so i think one of the
biggest advances in in machine learning
um in the last five or ten years has
been the development of the transformer
models that i'm talking about but of
course you can do language modeling with
a recurrent model that reads words in
order
um and of course lstms or stacked lstms
are sort of the standard way
way to do that
and you can compare what you actually
get if you study lstms versus versus
transformers and
at zeroth order uh it doesn't seem like
lstms are so bad it looks like as you
make them bigger they are scaling up
quite nicely but there's basically a
constant offset where transformers are
something like 5 or 10 times
more efficient for a given model size
than lstms
and so i think this is a very very
convincing plot that tells you that
transformers are in fact better but
but you don't necessarily need a
transformer to to see that making models
bigger is is giving you leaving you in
and really the sort of more interesting
limitation of lstms uh that i'll also
talk about a little more later
is if we plot something else so if we
look at
a thousand tokens which is something
like 600 words of context
we can look at what the loss is as a
function of the position in the context
because if you've read more of a
document already you're going to be
better at predicting what the next word
is because you have more context
available and they're very smooth it
turns out also power lock curves for uh
the loss as a function of context
position but the thing that you notice
is that the red lines are
lstms and the blue lines are
transformers and lstms tend to sort of
plateau in performance after on the
order of 100 tokens
and this is sort of another another a
bottleneck in a different direction
um
this is the famous fact that
transformers are much better at learning
long context information
and this is obviously a limitation of
lstms um but but sort of a basic
parameter scaling law uh seems like it
holds for for many architectures and
then there are much more refined
questions you can ask i won't go into
too much detail on this but there are
all sorts of hyper parameters in in
transformer models and you might ask how
much does it matter if i really optimize
those do i get qualitatively different
behavior if i optimize those better and
what all these plots show is that for
various different kinds of hyper
parameters and transformer models
there's some broad basin where you get
quite good performance i mean maybe a
factor of three in in either direction
where performance doesn't change all
that much
of course you might want to optimize
that i'm not saying you shouldn't but uh
but kind of qualitatively it's not it's
not an enormous
difference um
so i think this is also a place where
it's uh i i so i'm going to tell you in
a few slides that a lot of these
features are true more generally beyond
language
and they really sort of say that uh that
that much of what's going on when when
machines learn is is quite universal
but there are features that are are
non-universal so this is kind of a nicer
uh plot of loss versus token index
um
and i've included some power law fits
which are dotted lines which show that
uh uh
this is actually this this performance
is also is also highly predictable um
that just says the obvious that when you
read more you understand it's easier for
you to predict what's coming next um but
you can train models on images i'll
briefly talk about that later you could
train models identically on images and
there you see a performance as a
function of context position that's very
different so here
you have a model that reads pixels
row by row
and
as you might expect there's usually much
more non-trivial stuff going on in the
middle of an image rather than in the
background
and
that's represented by the fact that
models do much worse their loss is
higher in the center of images as
compared to
the edges so
while some properties of transformers
and language models are universal and
i'll talk about those uh
later on there are features of language
data that are totally different from
from other data distributions and this
is a very stark example of that
um but generally the fact that there are
these kinds of nice patterns lurking
whenever you optimize a model um i think
that is that is is very common
so any questions
um about this yeah
yeah so uh
so if you imagine you have a thousand
words extracted randomly from a book
then
the very first thing you can ask the
model to do is try to predict the very
first word
um then you ask it to predict the second
word the third word etc um
the very first word
basically all the model can possibly do
is predict the unigram distribution for
its training set that it just doesn't
have any information to go on otherwise
to predict what's happening and so
that's why its loss is very high
but by the time you get to the end of
the passage you've read some a lot of
some little short story and you know a
lot about what's going to happen you
know what kinds of words are likely to
to come next you know about the author's
style and vocabulary you know about what
characters exist et cetera um and so
your your model has gotten much much
better at prediction by by the end of
the context and so literally to make
this plot you take maybe a thousand ten
thousand different passages with a
thousand words in them
you compute the model's loss on
all of the words in the passage and then
you take the mean and you get some nice
plot like this
yeah
because
um
the
computational complexity
is quadratic
with respect to token index would that
mean that essentially for token index if
you think about it if you were looking
at compute
then it would go
uh
from the zeroth to like 10 to the sixth
so you know
you'd have significantly greater compute
for a given test loss as you increase
token index so um
it's true that if you make the context
length longer and longer you will spend
somewhat more compute
um
but the fraction of the amount of
compute you spend near the last token um
isn't isn't nearly so stark most of the
compute happens in the uh matrix
multiplies for
the mlp
feed forward part of the transformer and
also the
matrix multiplies to make the keys and
queries and values etc um that's
actually in in most well it depends on
it depends on the model hyperparameters
but in many models especially models
that are large that's actually the
predominant compute and so actually the
amount of compute you do for the last
token in the first token might only
differ by a few percent so for gpd3 i
think it's literally like one or two
percent difference
yeah yeah so i mean the formula for that
was this one that i i briefly mentioned
here so basically how much compute you
do in the context direction divided by
the amount of compute you do in the like
matrix multiply direction is this so if
your model is if d model is very small
like if d model is 128 and n context is
a thousand then it's basically 50 50.
but if d model is 10 000 and context is
2 000 then it's like two percent
so if the models keep getting bigger
then that means that if you're if you're
willing to pay a fractional cost then
you can keep making context length
longer and and pay a fixed fractional
cost um and of course if you use
something fancier than dense attention
you also get extra wins on top of that
any other questions
cool
um so
uh
this is sort of uh uh
both of these uh the left and the right
show you samples from uh a transformer
model
um
very roughly speaking they're identical
kinds of transformer models which is
with some slightly different hyper
parameters but they're trained on very
different data distributions the one on
the left is obviously this is gpd3 the
one on the right is uh igbt it's it's a
model that's trained to predict pixels
row by row and so what what happened
here was that uh we took the top half of
an image and then
generated all the rows uh rose beneath
and so the same kind of model
architecture but just trained on
different data distributions is sort of
able to effectively learn
very impressive uh uh
generative capabilities um in in in both
cases and so this is sort of a
qualitative hint at sort of the
possibility that what's going on here is
is quite universal
and um
and so
another way of introducing it to say you
might have some questions after the last
few slides are the scaling laws i'm
talking about really specific to
language are they a feature of the kinds
of data that language is
you might ask
do these scaling laws really continue
you showed that they're true over many
orders of magnitude but did they break
down eventually and in what way
and then another question you you might
ask is what do they imply for other
kinds of evaluations um you probably
don't just want to generate raw samples
from from either of these kinds of
models you might want to use them
for some other more specific tasks and
so there's a question of whether or not
um the test loss the training loss that
you've optimized
as that goes down in a predictable way
does that also imply that other things
other capabilities of the model are are
improving
so i'll be talking about these questions
so um this plot um
uh contains uh this plot contains kind
of a lot of compressed information all
at once or the set of plots so this is
the result of what happens if you train
the same kind of transfer models on uh
sort of five different data
distributions so text language we
already saw
but you can try
video where you predict every pixel in a
video i mean this sort of rectangle
rectangular prism of video pixels um
images
um this sort of synthetically generated
deepmind math math data set where you're
trying to predict the answer to math
problems
there's a multi-modal data set
where you have image text pairs
in either direction and in all cases
the x-axis is compute and the y-axis is
the appropriate test loss uh for for
that class of models
um
minus a a constant so uh
uh that's that's the one uh the one
complication that that i've added here
so
um
the the claim is that these dashed lines
in terms of the original loss
are
a
power law
um like the power laws that we saw on on
a much earlier slide
plus one constant term
um and if you subtract off that constant
term then and you make a log log plot
once again then you once again get these
very very nice straight lines um and so
this compute scaling law generalizes to
all these other data distributions and
the other scaling laws also generalize
um i just i just haven't plotted them um
so the claim of this slide is that
scaling laws do generalize to all of
these other data distributions when you
train the same basic kind of model
um
on them
and furthermore there's sort of an
intellectually slightly interesting
uh point which is that
if you really believe
that the sort of uh that these these
dashed lines are true do you think that
they're a real feature of what's going
on
and they continue out
very very very far
then if you think that the loss is a
constant plus a power law
then you can interpret the constant term
as
the entropy of the underlying data
distribution
and you can interpret the power law as
something like the kl divergence between
the true data distribution and the model
that you have
um
so
that's a lot the
important summary
at zeroth order to remember is that i'm
telling you that the kinds of scaling
laws i presented for language
generalized to all of these other other
domains there's also some other other
interesting features here
the reason why i used compute
to illustrate that the scaling laws
generalize
is because
you can ask another question now that
puts all of the different data
distributions on one plot
it wouldn't have made any sense to
combine the five plots on the last slide
into one plot because the test loss when
you're predicting a word is not in any
way comparable to the test loss when
you're predicting a pixel it doesn't
really make sense they don't have the
same units they don't
it doesn't make sense to put them
together
but something that does make sense to
put together is
what the optimal model size is as a
function of your computational budget
and so
um in the same way that we did for for
language you can go here and you can ask
for any given amount of compute like 10
to the minus two petaflop days what is
the best model size you can do that for
all of these plots
combine that information together and
you find something kind of surprising
which is that
again roughly speaking
if you're sort of willing to to to allow
a little bit of wiggle room um all of
these different kinds of models seem to
be on the same trajectory for optimal
model size uh versus versus compute um
there's some kind of universal fit of
how much bigger you should make your
model if you're going to model
any of these data distributions
with some given amount of compute
so
what about other kinds of tasks
well one of the most classic tasks that
you can ask about in ml is
image classification and so
um the models that we were training on
images and that that i've i've shown you
plots they're they're training laws um
these models are sort of on tiny little
images predicted pixel by pixel
in particular they're 32 by 32 images so
we can look at sort of the 32 by 32
pixel version of imagenet
classification and
the models that i was discussing are
generative models that predict pixels
but you can shop off their heads add a
classification head in in in its place
and try to predict imagenet and train on
imagenet and
the orange curve that i've shown you
here is what happens if you just take a
randomly initialized model with that
architecture and train it um you get
very good performance up to a point and
then performance plateaus because um
you're being limited by the fact that
imagenet is from this point of view a
small data set
however if you take these pre-trained
models that have been trained
generatively to to draw pixels they
they sort of use the features presumably
they're using the features they learned
from image generation
for classification and to get some nice
trend for the uh error rate in
classification
as a function of of model size so this
is saying that
uh in this particular case we actually
do fine-tuning um the pre-training that
you did and the sort of trends you saw
really kind of transfer into trends in
something else you might care about like
image classification
um
we can ask the same kinds of questions
about language models
in particular does this steady
improvement in language modeling as a
function of scale um does that translate
into into into better performance and
this is sort of an interesting subject
by itself so you can ask what happens if
we scale
uh language models and so this is sort
of this exact same plot that you've seen
a couple of times now for language
models but it just
increased from sort of original work
that we did out to this yellow line
which is which is gpt3
and you see that basically this the sort
of trends continue possibly gpd3 is sort
of missing the trend a little bit
um
i can't really honestly tell you whether
that's because gvd3 wasn't well
optimized or if it's because
uh
uh there's some bending in this curve
where we're hitting some irreducible
loss
that original loss would be something
like the entropy of the sort of language
data set uh itself
but
but it's just order the sort of trends
continue
and
what's now i think pretty well known is
that if you train fairly large language
models
then they can sort of exhibit in context
learning so
um
the kind of learning that that i'm
talking about is that you give these
models an example of many arithmetic
problems or many uh uh anagrams or
or what not or translation tasks for
individual words then um early on in the
sequence at the top they might not be
very good at doing the task but they
figure out what the pattern is in the
task and they learn to do it and in
particular you can you can plot that so
you can ask for say like one of these
anagram tasks um
what is the performance of the model as
a function of
how many examples of the task gets seen
in the context so this is kind of
similar to the loss as a function of
context position but it's now an
accuracy at doing an actual task like
unscrambling the letters in a word
and
you see
probably most importantly that
if you give more examples you get
significantly better performance
starting from very very poor performance
to to to pretty good and also you see
that larger models do this better
um you also finally see that giving a
natural language prompt with some
instructions helps significantly
in the regime where you have very few
examples um this is this is in context
learning it's you can call this a kind
of meta learning
um
and it just emerges automatically from
training large language models um
without uh without any particular
attempt to to get this kind of it's got
this kind of behavior
and you could also ask sort of about
downstream tasks that you actually you
care about
um
so there is accuracy at doing arithmetic
as a function of model size of a bunch
of different kinds of arithmetic
problems um
there's uh just some data set of
analogies from a
a test that american
college students take to to go to
college
um the sats
um and
i if you care the sort of average score
of that year's
test was i think 58 or so percent so the
largest model is sort of doing a little
bit better than the average
american high school student um
the
trivia qa which is sort of just knowing
trivia and uh winter grad schemas or
problems like uh if if a tree falls on
your roof
and you got it fixed what did you get
fixed did you get the tree fixed or your
roof
it's a measure of common sense reasoning
and models are also getting better at
this and i think the the other
interesting thing that's that's very
often
emphasized is that
clearly trivia performance is improving
very smoothly as you make models bigger
the models are just remembering more and
more trivia
winter grad schemas are also improving
fairly smoothly
but then there are examples like
arithmetic where models are very poor
and then they sort of suddenly get
pretty good
um and so these kind of sudden uh groks
where the model sort of suddenly
kind of like gets what it's supposed to
do for arithmetic are pretty interesting
i mean there are all sorts of other kind
of interesting things if you kind of dig
into these specific capabilities yeah
um
i mean i guess the sort of the sort of
dumb zeroth order point is that
larger models are just getting much
better and better at predicting
the next word given more and more
context so i think it like i think
there's a very tight connection between
a plot like this
and these sort of in context learning
plots um basically the more information
you're getting i mean all of these
models probably know the unigram
distribution of of words and tokens
pretty well um but the bigger model is
getting much much much more information
from its context than the smaller models
and at a certain point
i mean it depends on your training
distribution and all sorts of other
things but like
a certain one of the things that we do
is when we see several examples of
something happening in a text we guess
that that's that's what we're going to
we're going to see next and
that's really probably embedded in a ton
of text that's that's out there on the
internet and in books and
models have to decrease their loss
somehow that's a pattern in the text
it's a pattern that models eventually
learn and they
seemingly apply this knowledge i think
there are other people of course who've
kind of worked on this question more
specifically i might have more specific
theories but i think it like kind of a
intuitive sense that's that's how i
would think about it
um i guess one final evaluation you can
ask do can people tell that text written
by a language model was written by a
language model um or that it's a human
this is an evaluation where
uh
we looked at short news articles there's
i think two or three paragraphs and
generated equivalent news articles
from gpd3 and by the time you get to
sort of the largest models
people are approaching chance accuracy
of being able to tell the difference
this sort of has a lot of implications
both i mean it's it's
interesting and surprising as a
statement about language modeling um but
it's also uh it's also somewhat scary um
it means these language models are it's
very difficult to uh to tell that you're
talking to to a language model if you
don't have a very long conversation
um
yeah
hi um so i'm wondering
okay so for this specific story for
events because um with monitoring models
they are more prone to memorization so
have you examined like if the
generation's article
that's a great question i actually don't
know the answer to that question for
this particular analysis off the top of
my head um
i
believe that they uh that these are not
memorized um one simple thing you can do
at least for
for some things that occur frequently is
like you can look at the distribution of
the loss for a model on its own samples
um and at least for for things that are
memorized they're they're very clearly
memorized um
usually they of course probably they
occur frequently in the training set but
also the loss tends to be like much much
lower on memorized samples because i
mean you can sort of intuitively
understand this because like if there's
100 words that are exactly verbatim uh
sampled out and you're sampling it's
sort of temperature equals one then all
of the next word predictions have to be
extremely extremely confident and that
means the loss has to be super low so i
mean just informally something that i've
done to just get rid of memorized
samples is compute the loss and usually
you'll just see a pretty clear bimodal
where there will be a few memorized
examples and then things that aren't um
that's a simple thing you can do to
check you can also of course do
deduplication i i don't remember off the
top of my head what deduplication was
done here
um on the though
tasks section is there more to say about
how scaling
did you look at um
context and adversarial
um
i don't think i have anything
particularly
clear to say about that
um
i mean these these evals i think are not
adversarial in the sense that they're
just uh they're just a few shot
evaluations with some some fixed data
set
um there are a large number of different
kinds of adversarial data sets out there
for
reasoning for for common sense knowledge
for for truthfulness so i mean there's
like for example truthful qa
famously is an example where there
aren't any trends like this and arguably
the trends go downward although it
depends on your training distribution
and some models actually do improve so i
think uh i think that's a complicated
question i think it's hard to find
examples where the trends go down i
don't think it's easy but but
these do exist
any other questions
great
so
i guess i'll sort of end by summarizing
some some lessons that you might draw
kind of pretty practically for for
research from this um
and then i can either open it up for
questions or or i can i can also i could
always talk infinitely long i've been a
professor for like 10 years of my life
so i can just talk forever um but but
i'll sort of end after talking about
some some lessons um so i think one
lesson that kind of i draw from this is
that kind of scanning over some of the
important inputs to your training
process is just
a pretty useful thing to do when you're
doing ml research
and it's sort of
typically very cheap it's cheap because
generally most things vary in an
important way on a log scale or sort of
on a geometric scale however you want to
say it um and that means that like if
you're training with the data set of
size d maybe you should also train with
d over two and d over four and d over
eight or something like that and if you
sum that geometric series you get 2d so
you sort of i mean you made your
trending process twice as expensive in
some sense but uh but it's not really
it's not really a big change in in what
you have to do but you can often like
learn a lot about what's going on by by
doing these kinds of scans and so i mean
this is an example of some some data
that i didn't show earlier but
something you might wonder about is what
happens if you scan over data set size
and model size at the same time
and it turns out there's some very
simple trends that you can model in that
case too that tell you about things like
overfitting
and i mean if you care about overfitting
then this tells you about something like
how big you have to make your data set
for a given model size to avoid
overfitting being a significant problem
so that you can answer all kinds of
questions like that um and i at least
find that this this is kind of useful
and uh and it's nice
um
for learning things about about behavior
and i think alongside that i think like
um this is this is sort of a joke this
isn't real this is sort of making fun of
a large number of machine learning
papers that you you might see
um i think a lot of machine learning
papers have tables like this um and it's
sort of hard to tell from like this kind
of table obviously i'm making fun but i
think it's not so unrealistic like did
the technique that went into our model
really improve on on other things that
happened um and i think that this kind
of plot at least for me is a much more
convincing statement that like well
clearly transformers are just better
than lstms um so
the slogan here is sort of success for
new techniques if your goal is to sort
of improve a model um uh
if that is your goal then i think it's
it's it's at least to me much more
convincing and kind of clear what's
going on if you see these trends um
maybe i have another slide
making fun of this yeah so i mean i
think this is a thing that i actually
see very often in research um is that
you come up with some new idea and um
you
see like
you first do the cheapest easiest
experiment and you see well my new idea
improved performance i'm really excited
um uh everyone should should adopt this
and um but then you you make some plot
like this and you sort of say oh okay i
guess it it doesn't really matter that
much uh at all
and i think this is this is actually a
comment i mean i think we all have all
sorts of ideas
i mean
people people
fall asleep at night and they can't
sleep and then they wake up and they
they have ideas and like oh i'm gonna go
try this we all do it um but uh but
oftentimes they don't work and i think
this this is sort of useful for
understanding whether your idea really
really works um
and i mean if all you're ever gonna do
is train this model then your idea did
work but i think that like there's sort
of an expectation that uh that
that probably people will be
using bigger computers to train larger
models in the future and so the ideas
that are really going to have a huge
impact are ones that sort of point to
the opposite direction um i've even seen
ideas where on small models they make no
difference at all but on larger models
they they they do better um and uh uh
and so this these kinds of trends i
think are useful
um and they're certainly useful to think
about um
another point that uh that i find useful
um
uh i think it's not sort of obvious and
maybe you shouldn't trust it completely
is that i tend to think i mean because
i've sort of swallowed my own kool-aid
um uh that if something works then it
should scale fairly predictably that's
not always true but for things that you
can measure
that are very close to your optimization
target um
if sort of your training for your
training process your hyper parameters
etc are all kind of set up well then i i
tend to think that you should see some
kind of predictable trend and if that
trend uh goes away
then i mean maybe that's just that's
just exactly what's true but i think
often it means that there's something
broken about about what's going on maybe
your numerics are broken and you need
higher precision in some part of your
model maybe uh maybe there's some
bottleneck you hadn't thought of um so i
mean
this is also an example that kind of
scaling predictable scaling kind of can
be found all over the place so
um i i just think this is sort of neat
um so if you just train these extremely
naive very stupid multimodal models or
use a decoder only transformer to either
model the text based on the image or
model the image based on the text
then
you can measure a sort of empirical
mutual information between the image and
the text how much information did the
image give you about the words um
in the sense of sort of shannon
information um and or conversely how
much information did the text give you
about the image and
this is also a place where i mean this
is very close to the optimization target
the whole point of the multi model is to
is to get this information and you see
that there's some
predictable scaling going on where
larger models are getting more
information
about one data just what one part of the
distribution for for for the other um
but i think this is sort of a general
thing that uh that you should expect um
in in model training
um and so maybe to sort of summarize
maybe
even bigger picture implications um
i think that these kinds of results
suggest that
um
it may not be the best or the smartest
or the most interesting way to to make
better ml models maybe it won't be the
the way that uh that happens in the
future but at least i think these
results kind of suggest that there
aren't any really hard conceptual
barriers preventing people from training
significantly more powerful models of
all sorts of
of all kinds including of course
language models um in in ai research
i think
certainly my perspective
originally as a physicist sort of coming
to machine learning um
uh kind of you know sort of fresh new
way five years ago um is that i mean
this this is sort of one set of
abstractions for thinking about kind of
what's going on in
in ai research um that
you
if you're going to be training fairly
large models and you want them to do
well that's a thing that you're going to
do um then you probably want your models
to sort of be scaling well in terms of
their performance and i think this this
framework of maybe there's a bottleneck
but if you remove the bottleneck then
then you'll just continue to see further
progress um i've i've found found useful
um
uh i think another point that that uh
uh well maybe i'll make this point at
the end uh another point is that uh yeah
scaling laws are just sort of all over
the place and and they can help you to
sort of uh uh maybe organize your
research a bit um
and then i mean maybe the most
interesting point conceptually though is
that it seems like
if you believe this kind of story that
it seems like
many domains of ml are kind of
surprisingly simple and and universal
things that you might not have thought
are the same or more similar than they
are different
um and of course this is also a
fascinating thing to try to to
understand so um
i mean i was a theoretical physicist for
most of my life so i mostly tried to uh
like understand things that seem
extremely esoteric and weird and why
would anyone care about them um this is
a thing that that i think probably
probably everyone in this room kind of
cares about like can ai models write can
they can they communicate in language
and
um
these kinds of trends are really really
nice they're the kind of trends that you
might see in a very controlled physics
experiment or something um and yet
they're coming out of something very
very noisy and random like predicting
language data data on the internet so i
think it's very interesting to think
about like
why
are these kinds of trends true what is
the underlying kind of theory or or
science here that makes these trends
true can we predict it
can we refine those predictions can we
understand why when this doesn't doesn't
occur
another question is sort of there's some
exponent here this is a straight line
but the straight line represents a power
law with a particular exponent why that
exponent
for language it's like 0.08 or so y 0.08
and not .2 or 0.4 or 0.001
i think there are all sorts of questions
here when you see
data that has a very clear trend it's
very interesting to understand to try to
think about
why is something so so simple happening
and i'll sort of leave you with that
[Applause]
your picture is essentially
make everything bigger avoid bottlenecks
and will be good
whereas i guess for
human beings so you're you're good on
the number of parameters because there's
still several waters magnitude headroom
there
but it seems
like
you're
not very good on the amount of compute
so human computers very constrained both
in their same mouth
using most of their parameters most of
the time
um and today there's a little bit
complex because i guess we get a ton of
you know there's live video data coming
at us all the time but certainly if
you're
thinking
about the amount of language data we get
you know
um sort of fully confident language
users are sort of three orders will make
the shoot down from where dpt3 is now
and
um but yet something good seems to
happen as human abilities to learn um
any thoughts on that i mean i think it's
a fantastic question i don't have
anything to say that isn't quite
speculative
um
so i mean i don't have any good answer
to the question i think it's a great
question
i guess one thing that seems like it's
true is that sort of a factor of a
thousand you mentioned seems pretty
common um
i mean my impression is that alphago
probably plays like a thousand times
more games when it trains than uh uh
than like a gomaster does um i think i
think this is a pretty common factor to
see in a lot of like ml ml contexts but
i have no idea why it is i don't know if
it's that evolution optimized us to
learn fast if we have some hard-coded
information if the sort of multi-modal
inputs that we have help a lot
you might imagine that when you have a
system that's already pretty smart
reinforcement learning or active
learning of some form becomes more and
more important because like
when these language models or or a
person like if i read if i read a
physics textbook i don't really learn a
lot in a certain sense
because i already learned physics and i
think the same is probably true for
these models so as the models get
smarter
this sort of very dumb next word
prediction task is giving you less and
less information but you might expect to
get more and more information
uh if you if you did something more more
active i can continue to speculate but
yeah it's it's i i don't i don't really
know anything about uh i don't have
anything uh
sort of
well established to tell you um it's a
great question
the transformers were a bit better but
they were sort of similar because it
seems like
human ability to learn
relative to
yeah i think that's absolutely i think
it just true i mean the sample
efficiency of these models is not
similar i i mean another way of saying
is just that
if you got into ai research to
understand the human brain it's very
unclear whether we're making any
progress on that but uh but but if we
just wanna sort of uh yeah if we if
for a lot of these tasks that doesn't we
don't seem to have to solve the brain to
solve uh to solve ai surprisingly
that when we have larger and larger
logos are we gonna have like good high
quality data that we can use to actually
and also
there's also like things that will
probably have never really been like
knowledge that humans have that probably
aren't necessarily being written
and like things like
sure sure no these are all great
questions um
so
i mean
sort of early on i commented on some
sources of data and i mean you're
certainly correct about quality um i
think in terms of quantity i mean i
don't think anyone has the like a
digitized library of congress but i
think if you did that would be like i
don't know maybe 10x bigger than the
training set for gpd3 so there's a sense
in which there's probably
quite a lot of
still quite high quality data that isn't
in use um i don't know whether it will
ever be in use
it's a complicated question um and then
if you if you are willing to sort of
take all of this garbage on the internet
um or try to filter that garbage down um
i think
i i don't know how accurate this
estimate is but in order of magnitude
level you can get something like 10 to
the 15 words which is a thousand times
bigger and of course if you find any
kind of intelligent way of filtering
then uh if you if you could filter down
to 0.1 percent of that and take the 0.1
percent that's best then you do still
have a lot of data so i think for
language modeling there's definitely
still some headroom um but this is this
is certainly a a constraint um and uh
and there are other kinds of data
distributions where where you'll you'll
run out sooner i mean in terms of uh
uh
yeah i mean of course there are all
sorts of other things one can explore
wanting to explore multimodal models one
can switch to a different kind of loss
function um that is more interactive or
actually accomplishing a task but uh but
i think for pure language modeling it
seems like there's at least some room
left and if you think that your model
size increases sort of if you if you
think you can increase your model size
by a factor of 100 and increase your
data set size by a factor of 10 which is
sort of like
roughly what
roughly what this is saying if you
believe that
then you can still scale up your model
size a lot and have probably plenty of
data um but uh yeah we're very i mean if
you couldn't sort of do this stuff
without the internet
yeah or you know
do you want
sure yeah um in terms of bottlenecks for
um
improvement over time
are you more optimistic about
um
progress in hardware systems like
enabling much larger models on the same
architectures or
um
i guess i mean i i think i'm sort of
optimistic about both um i think that
my understanding sort of the zeroth
order understanding of the hardware
situation is that like
connecting together gpus and gpu like
objects works pretty well and that like
uh interconnection speeds
are increasing and can increase pretty
easily so i think that uh you don't need
one chip to run your entire model you
can distribute your model over many many
many
many accelerators and i think uh i think
you can do that if you're willing to pay
for those accelerators et cetera then i
think i think you can do that um
architectural improvements i think
uh i would say sort of
i typically haven't been super excited
about architectural improvements but uh
but
i i i think there will continue to be
architectural improvements i think that
sort of whenever you do something for
the first time or even just like
whenever you train a really big model
for the first time you sort of don't do
it in the best possible way and and
there's a lot of
like all sorts of different kinds of
improvements maybe there are sort of
non-incremental improvements that will
look like big jumps um so yeah i i think
i think there will be both um so yeah i
mean there's a sense in which
if all you did was look at this plot and
just try to continue it that might be an
underestimate of progress that the field
is going to make because there will be
uh
there will be improvements in in
architecture and algorithms and things
like that
just like how we do that advertising
computer vision
but like maybe big bad steps
and then you can theoretically have
increasingly growth you know just
skating along
like
fall apart or getting forced by this
type of like almost synthetic
i think that's a great question
um
i think the sort of simplest version of
this well a simple version of it that i
think is probably important and
increasingly important is sort of
just reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning in a certain
sense is a situation where you generate
your own data because like if you have a
language model doing rl then it writes
something and then you're training on
that data so i i definitely do think
that that will sort of augment data and
mean that uh that that there will be
other avenues for improvement um literal
data augmentation itself seems also
seems plausible to me i think it's not
happening a lot because there still is
more just language data out there but
yeah um so i have two questions
uh
just coming from a non-computer science
background just interested like how
like what about especially with the
language field
i don't know i got really excited about
physics and the second part is
uh you know in your research before this
i'm sure you've done a lot with
different types of skills you know
because i stopped
are there any findings that you found
particularly surprising or unexpected uh
you know just with your your past
experiences at least when i look at this
a lot of it looks like
is
i think to me the most surprising thing
is uh
of these
sorts of results was probably that there
is a very very precise trend it seems
like i mean
yeah i mean like i i think this is this
is sort of an unusual thing and i think
when i saw that i thought it was a
really big deal um i think that like
usually like i mean it's just it's not
true in most many things you plot i mean
obviously there are other plots that
don't show this kind of trend even if
they're reasonable i mean like like i
don't know i mean there's sort of a
trend in trivia qa but but i don't
really know what that means but i think
i think i think the fact that there's
something seemingly very precise is
i i view that as like a very intriguing
entry point to like try to dig into
something because it means that there's
probably some deeper reason and then the
fact that it's seems fairly universal
across data distributions again suggests
suggest something like that um
yeah the main difference between data
distributions is the these exponents uh
in the scaling laws are different um in
terms of like coming from physics
i mean i think i got into like a lot of
this stuff partly because i'm fairly
mercurial and and i was i was interested
and a lot of other friends i had were
interested and so we sort of studied it
and and it went from there i
had friends etc um
uh but i mean from another point of view
i think i got involved in it uh for
really weird reasons perhaps in the
sense that like i just know a lot of
people who are already in sort of
i don't know 2015 talking about things
like wow is like uh are how much better
is ai going to get
what are the implications going to be
for the world
is this going to keep improving at a
drastic clip
what are we going to do to sort of make
sure that these models are aligned with
human values to use the kind of usual
sort of phrase that's that's that's now
used um and uh and i sort of thought
these people were weird and crazy even
though they were friends of mine and i
sort of said oh like this is this is
really dumb like i don't think that
these ai models are really something to
worry about
um but like i was still interested
and uh and and and sort of was like well
like smart people i know think that ai
is improving very rapidly um and and and
that might have a lot of impacts and
might require a lot of sort of caution
and thought and and work to sort of make
it safe and uh and so that was actually
a significant motivation for me getting
involved it was a mixture of sort of
uh
there being a lot of potentially really
intellectually interesting questions um
liking to sort of switch fields every
few years um and uh and friends of mine
being being very kind of concerned about
this question and uh
and
yeah that was sort of what brought me in
yeah
what factor have you found has the most
potential to
throw off
this
um
i mean if we go back to sort of very
basic ml ingredients
um of like
what are these things like
so if there's a sense in which this is
all you're doing you choose one of each
of these five things um
i i would guess that uh what the
objective is is most likely to sort of
change things in the sense that
predicting the next word is really sort
of one of the laziest sort of dumbest
things you can do um
and uh and and i mean there are all
sorts of things so it's really just
chosen because you want to be able to
compute you want to be able to do back
prop and so you want to be able to get
some differentiable thing you want to be
able to get a lot of data for which you
can compute this differentiable thing
and so that so you so you that's that's
that's the game that you're playing um
but i think that you can have other
objectives
like through reinforcement learning or
or some other some other kind of uh
active learning whatever i mean some
combination of such things um
and i i sort of would just guess that uh
generally performance will change a lot
more um like if you're expecting sort of
these trends to be very different i
would guess they're different if you
have a different objective i think
changing the data distribution or the
model might also change things but uh
but i think that like the lesson that i
personally draw from something like this
is that even if you found a like really
revolutionary change that was like much
better than transformers um it might be
kind of equivalent to making
transformers ten times bigger but uh but
i'm not sure if that would be as big of
a deal as changing the loss um
changing what the objective is but
that's just my guess i have no idea um
and of course this paradigm
i mean
i think i was trying to be polite i
usually have like a picture of a grilled
cheese here um to emphasize like sort of
how simple and sort of silly this is
rather than this sort of very uh
sophisticated palette of spices um and i
mean maybe someone will say like this
isn't the right set of ingredients from
which to think about things and there's
a different thing you should do and
maybe that will make a big difference as
well but i
that's sort of an unknown unknown